die jeden wunsch christa mir ins ohr
rein für dich völlig gegen alle kämpfen
wie bei ford
ist das problem
an die cooper cos
ich verkenne frei von shanghai
an der copacabana
alles war fertig
[Musik]
wirklich harte proben denke deine beine
und jetzt
[Musik]
sie wollte
mit 2 bis 9
kleine spaß was klar warum ich so gut
drauf bin es ist nämlich gerade vier uhr
nachts und ich freue mich schon richtig
drauf euch als klartext hören was ihr
wolltet eigentlich nur das video davor
sehen euch interessieren die wir schon
fast gar nicht ich mache nicht die
regeln wir fangen an geld mit diesem
geilen schotte ja unter sehen wir
nämlich wie die drei damen da so sitzen
ok über geld da gehe ich sofort einen
rein gehst du den creative server rein
baus team green screen auf und dann
posten weil wir damit paar waffen und
dann bin ich auch schon hier in effects
drin und dann muss sie natürlich diese
zwei damen links und rechts weg kriegen
weil die wolle ersetzen habe ich direkt
man dieses bild hier in photoshop
gemacht wo ich dann die beiden doch
reduziert hat dann habe ich das
retuschierte bild trübe gelegt und an
dem punkt dachte ich okay wie geil wäre
es eigentlich ein musikvideo die schiris
auf mega krass macht und dann ist sie
einfach die ganze zeit immer nur alleine
ultra traurig gut aber vorne bringt mehr
klicks deswegen haben auch hier schon
dem clip von dem ford als kinder nicht
hineingezogen habe gut dass grüne an der
stelle ist natürlich nicht so schön
machen wir mal weg sagt so habe noch ein
bisschen bisschen mehr hose ins spiel
gebracht und jetzt ist der shop auch
schon fertig so auch bei diesem schuss
war natürlich der magie zu gange auch
hier muss ich als erstes wieder das
mädel loswerden weil ganz ehrlich wer
will da mit dem echten mädchen abhängen
wenn man auch mit dem fordern skin
abhängen kann
das habe ich so gemacht dass sie quasi
die wieder in photoshop aus reduziert
habe und dann quasi das einfach über sie
drüber gelegt habt ja ist nicht perfekt
aber das reicht auf jeden fall dafür
dann habe ich die bewegung von leon
macht er quasi gespeichert und hat diese
bewegung quasi auf den fans kennen drauf
gesetzt sodass es können sie aus wie das
wird dir aufstecken ich glaube ihr
versteht das prinzip bisher nie
gekannten verbessert ja bisher die
farben deutlich verbessert werden hier
noch mal die farben krass verändert und
jetzt passt so viel mehr in diese
sonnenuntergang stimmung richtig
romantisch wir haben einfach eine geile
zeit ja dafür habe ich jetzt diese nacht
durchgemacht wenn ihr bock hab auch
sowas zu lernen sie ganze magie und so
weiter und so fort visual effects ein
bisschen schnitt auch ich bring
demnächst kurse raus ja ich bring euch
das bei wenn ihr das lernen wollt folgt
man auf instagram behalte ich euch am
laufenden und dann wenn er mich auf
diese reise begleiten möchte und noch
mehr von dem zeug sehen wollt dann
abonniert mich haut auch diese kleine
glocke drei motiv als sich dagegen
verschworen meine videos auszuschütten
da bin ich mir recht sicher und dann
sehen wir uns beim nächsten und dann
sehen uns beim nächsten juli damals gut
warum